قررت بولندا ارسلها عشره الاف عسكريا الى
حدودها مع بيلاروسيا بدعم الامن على
الحدود المشتركه بين البلدين وحضرت بولندا
وهي عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي من خطر
استفزازات مصدرها الجره بيلاروسيا ومن
المخاطر المحتمله التي تشكلها مجموعه فاجن
الروسيه التي انتقلت الى بيلاروسيا
هذا وقال وزير الدفاع البولنديه ماريوشا
بلاش تشاكا قال لنا تعزيز قوات حرس الحدود
البولنديه المتمركزه على الحدود مع الجاره
بيلاروسيا اجراء يهدف الى حمايه بلاده
وردع اي اعتداء عليها
فيصل تعداد قواتنا على الحدود الى نحو
عشره الاف جندي 4000 منهم سينخرطون بشكل
مباشر في العمليه الهادفه الى دعم حرس
الحدود في حين سيبقى 6000 جندي في وضع
الاحتياط هؤلاء الجنود سيتواجدون هناك
لتطوير قدراتهم في القواعد العسكريه في
الجزء الشرقي من بلادنا
من جانبيه قال رئيس بيلاروسيا
ان بلاده لا تنوي قتال احد وان الحوار مع
بولندا قد يؤدي الى تحسين العلاقات معها
حسب تعبيره واكذلك انه اصدر للحكومه
ووزاره الخارجيه امرا باقتراح خطه سلاما
مع مو وصفهم بالجيران الغربيين داعيا
شركات الطيران الغربيه الى العوده الى
بيلاروسيا اضافنا بولندا ليست من يصعد
التوتر مع بلاده بشكل منفرد وانما الول
ايات المتحده هي من تدفعها للقيام بذلك
على حد تعبيره
ينضم الينا من الحدود البولنديه
البيلاروسيه مراسم الجزيره نور الدين
بوزيان نور الدين كيف تبدو الاجواء على
الحدود بعد قرار نشر 10,000 جندي بولندي
جلال لحد هذه الساعه الهدوء هو الذي يخيم
على هذه المنطقه انا اقف الان مثلا امام
هذه البوابه الحدوديه بين بولندا من الجهه
البولنديه الى بيلاروسيا ولعلك تشاهد بان
المكان ساكن فقط هذه الاضواء الحمراء
والخضراء حيث تدخل وتخرج بعض الدوريات
التابعه لحرس الحدود البولندي لعل التطور
الذي سيؤكد بان هناك
تصعيدا ما بين البلدين وفي منطقه الحدود
هو وزير الدفاع البولندي سيقوم غدا بعد
الظهر بزياره الى المنطقه الحدوديه هذا
التطور او هذه الزياره جاء من بعد ان اعلن
وزير الدفاع رساله تعزيزات الى المنطقه
الحدوديه وقال بالحرف الواحد باننا سنقوم
بدحر اي جهه تحاول استفزازنا او تحاول
المرور باتجاهنا وهناك من يقول في الحقيقه
جمال انها سبب هذا التوتر ليس فقط تداعيات
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا وانما ايضا
انتشار مجموعه مسلحه من التابعين لمجموعه
فاغنر وهذا الذي اشار اليه المسؤولون
البولنديون خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
عندما قال بان هناك استفزازات تحاول ان
تقوم بها مجموعه فاجنر وبعض اعضاء الحكومه
في الحقيقه ذهبوا الى ابعد من ذلك عندما
قالوا بان مجموعه تحاول الان استغلال
الموجات الكبيره من المهاجرين واللاجين
الذين يوجدون خلف هذه البوابه وعلى الحدود
البولنديه البيلاروسيه لكي يقتحموا بولندا
عموما يمكن القول بان الجهات البولنديه
تقول باننا لا نقلل من خطر ما وقع في
المده الاخيره في اشاره واضحه الى خرق
طائرتين من سلاح الجو البيولوسي الاجواء
هنا وقالوا باننا اصبحنا في مواجهه احتمال
ربما ان تنفلت الامور في اي لحظه من
اللحظات لكن اليوم كما ذكر ت جمال انت
هناك على ما يبدو دعوات من الطرف الاخر من
اجل الحوار لا نعرف الى اي مدى سيستجيب
لها الطرف البولندي على كل حال ربما
سيتحدث في الموضوع غدا عندما يزور هذه
المنطقه وزير الدفاع البولندي جمال
بالانتظار بانتظار ذلك شكرا لك مراسل
جزيلا نور الدين بوزيان المتحدثا الينا من
الحدود البولنديه البيلاروسيه
[موسيقى]